hi everybody my name is Winston Chang
I'm a software engineer at earth studio
and today I'm going to be talking about
doing interactive graphics with SHINee
there are a bunch of code examples which
you can see at this URL at the bottom on
github and the and the slides are
available there too okay so here's an
overview of what I'm gonna talk about
today so first I'm going to talk about
different kinds of graphics and what
we'd use them for so so there are static
versus interactive graphics static
graphics are you know the traditional
plots that you would see you might print
them out
you can't interact with them and
interactive ones obviously are things
that you can interact with by state
using your mouse
there are graphics for different
purposes so for example you might have a
graphic for presentation like if you're
creating a report that you want to
display to somebody or for publication
and there's data graphics for exploring
your data so if you're still in the data
analysis process or you know in X you
know exploratory data analysis phase you
know what you're trying to learn
something about your data that's that's
another purpose raising a data graphic
as opposed to for presentations so after
that I'm going to talk about the nuts
and bolts of actually creating integrate
interactive graphics with shrining and
so we'll get into some code and after
that I'm going to talk about using
creating shiny gadgets which are those
are it's using shiny for the data
exploration phase and this is a new
feature that we've added in shiny 0.13
which was released a month ago oh and I
should also mention that the interactive
graphics features were added in the last
year ok so if when we're thinking about
data graphics one question that well one
issue that's important when thinking
about them is is a graphic static or is
it interactive
so here are a bunch of static graphics
these are all generated by are these
should all be probably all look familiar
to you some one of the most basic thing
we can do in our is to create to create
visualizations like this so up here we
have a histogram created by the hist
function here we have a scatterplot
created by the plot function with a oh
well this one actually also has a linear
regression a line edit as well and then
over here we have a box plot and these
these graphics and are these are all
part of database our package and they're
all here I mean they're all they're all
static it's it's sort of the way that
things evolved you know before before
our existed these types of graphics
existed and they were targeted towards
probably mostly towards print
publication or printing out you know
creating printouts for reports and you
know back a long time ago people drew
these out by hand and then after once
computers came around and were able to
generate some of these they were they
could generate these figures but they
were still meant for printing on paper
and they tended to not have a lot of
interactive features so that's that's
sort of the heritage of of these types
of plots so more recently this is not
like really recent history but more
recently there have been interactive
graphical systems like this this is a
screenshot this is actually two
screenshots of of a program called G
goby which allows one to interact with
the data and explore it so all of these
these plots are linked in this example
this is not a live example this is a
screenshot but it lets you take a look
at the subset of this data so like like
this yellow highlighted region the data
here corresponds to the highlighted bits
here and in these scatter plots and in
these bars here and and then in this
second plot on the right or the second
set of plots on the right there's a
larger region that's selected here and
the other corresponding points are
highlighted
this sort of tool was used for is
designed for data exploration I'm still
trying to learn something about your
data but it's not targeted toward
presentation for you know obviously you
know you can't use this for print output
because you're not going to be able to
interact with a printed page and and but
even on you know even sharing this over
a computer is difficult because other
people might not have the software and
the software to run the same sort of
visualization that you've created here
okay so let's second question which I've
hinted at already is what is the purpose
of the graphic so for data graphic you
might use them for in the exploratory
phase of your data analysis so here's an
example I'm looking at this histogram of
the built in data set in R it's about
geyser eruptions Old Faithful so I run
histogram here it looks like this and I
decide well what if I want to look at
the histogram in a little bit more
detail with smaller bin size well I can
just tweak a parameter and and then it
looks like this
sorry I missed again with a greater
number of breaks or greater number of
bins in other words and and then it
looked like this and you know by
tweaking these parameters during the
data exploration phase you might be able
to learn something new about the data
but these are you know it's not these
are not all meant to be shared with
other people this might just this is
just for me to learn something about the
data okay and then once you're done
doing your data exploration and learning
about your data and processing it you
might generate data graphics for
presentation so this is just a page out
of a book it's got these line graphs and
these are meant for you know this isn't
meant for the data analyst or the
researcher to learn about the data this
is meant to communicate some findings to
readers in this case readers of a book
so it could be you know print a print
article or just you know a report
printed report
or something that's on a webpage
dashboard perhaps mm-hmm okay so the
state of data graphics about five years
ago was that well you could generate
there's tools for generating static
graphics for the data exploration phase
and this is a screenshot of that we saw
before but there's plenty of other tools
I mean even you know excel can generate
static graphics that you can use for
data exploration those same graphics
once you finish your data analysis they
could be used for presentation maybe
tweak them to look a little bit nicer
but they're essentially the same thing
and for for the data exploration phase
there were interactive tools like G goby
which you know good for learning
something about your data but it's more
difficult to use them to for
presentation to communicate those
findings telling people for for mostly
for technical reasons but this left is
that so there's this quadrant other
quadrant here that was sort of left
unfilled so interactive graphics for
presentation hmm well in in the last few
years that's changed quite a bit so here
are some examples from the New York
Times these are examples of data
journalism they do a really good job
with these so here's the leaders two
screenshots I'll show you these live get
the web browser up here
okay so here's an interactive tax text
well hmm Explorer like are you receiving
a marriage penalty or bonus so the idea
is that in the United States if you file
your taxes as a married couple jointly
versus filing separately as two single
people you may end up paying more in
taxes or less if you're even if you have
the same amount of income so for example
you know so I just picked this number up
here if your you're part of a couple and
you earn 81 thousand dollars here and
all of that is earned by one partner and
the other partner doesn't have any
income then then if you file as a
married couple then you save we pay five
thousand three hundred dollars less in
taxes so whereas if you're up here where
you know both partners and about the
same amount and then if then if you file
as a married couple then you actually
pay more in taxes than you would if you
filed a single so so this this graphic
has some basic interactive features you
know you can you can hover over it and
it'll tell you some information so if
you want to find out like you know I'm a
couple or a couple and you know one
person makes this much money the other
person makes it the so the amount of
money you can get some detailed
information about how much of a bonus or
penalty your pain in Texas and that's
something that you know that it adds a
lot to this graphic if you just if you
just see this graphic like this you know
a lot of that information is there but
it's a little bit harder to interpret
and it's it's it's it's harder to find
yourself on here like what these these
various incomes I like on this on the
x-axis here it's a total income and the
y-axis is the percentage split that's
earned by each partner okay so that's
one